lesquels le centre ville de petit il
s'échappe la non moins tranquille rue du
capitaine joseph soit qu une jolie rue
où les coquette résidence jouissent d'un
verdoyant paysage dans ce chemin où le
soleil couchant et tire les ombres celle
de joseph swaco est-elle encore
présentes qui était chose à 5 ans il
n'avait pas nous vous me posez la
question je vous retourne six mois je
sais pas j'étais un grand chef
c'était ma faute du quartier je connais
un peu savent animé des mêmes les
baronnies c'était le capitaine de l'en
je veux faire la guerre en indochine la
gueule interpellé le
c'était lapointe tellement si la commune
de petite île est fière de josette swaco
c'est qu'il fut un héros de la guerre
d'indochine
né dans une famille modeste de
petite-île joseph soit qu est un élève
brillant ses parents analphabètes
l'encouragent donc dans la voie des
études et il devient instituteur à 18
ans il enseigne au guillaume saint paul
et à saint joseph
mais rapidement la guerre éclate il est
mobilisé et termine la guerre dans les
forces françaises libres comme
sous-lieutenant de l'infanterie
coloniale mais c'est en indochine où il
est affecté dès 1946 qu'il est surnommé
la panthère noire par le vietminh rodez
à la guérilla il monte en grade et
reçoit cinq citations pour sa bravoure
après un court repos au pays
il se porte volontaire et retourne au
front en indochine
pendant huit ans il combat pour ramener
la paix et la sécurité dans la zone de
longtan promu capitaine en janvier 1954
il est blessé au combat le 11 mai de la
même année comprimant la blessure de son
flanc droit d'une main il poursuit la
lutte est mort quelques heures plus tard
sans une plainte
il n'a que 35 ans titulaire de la croix
de guerre des médailles militaires et
des territoires d'extrême orient et
d'indochine
il aura fait l'objet de 12 citations au
cours de sa carrière militaire il repose
maintenant dans le cimetière de sa ville
natale
si vous passez près de matane fait au
moins une minute de silence parce que
jvc tous mes amis là où j'ai combattu
ces derniers par an